non so ragazzi se avete presente però
quando i fan inviare i pacchi arrivi ad
un punto in cui continui a riceverne e
se non fai video dove aprì pacchi si
accumulano uno sopra l'altro e formano
una pila che diventa gigante quindi un
certo punto devi iniziare ad aprirli
perché sennò ti sfratti la casa quei
pacchi provate a indovinare che cosa
facciamo oggi ragazzo a livelli magari
la prossima volta gli appoggio dritti
che dite a tutti i ragazzi e per minuti
a questo nuovo video sono farisei giudei
inviare in un nuovo blog prima di
cominciare ragazzi come al solito
partiamo con la farà della settimana che
questa settimana è stata vinta da ecco
nel prendere i pacchi mi sono
dimenticato di vedere che cazzo ha fatto
la fan art non so se c'è scritto c'è
scritto passiamo al prossimo punto
ragazze c'è una news che vi devo dire
che mirata l'ho già detta su facebook ma
devo dirla in un blog perché una cosa
che dovete tenervi forte credo anche di
poter affermare che il video più ai
limiti dell'essere umano che ho fatto e
con questo intendo che mi sono
ridicolizzato che la metà abbassava che
è anche abbastanza vecchio resto che ci
penso c'è un video su just dance che
avevo fatto tipo nel 2013 quindi tipo
tre anni fa
siccome negli anni ho continuato a fare
video di just dance successo che la
ubisoft e quelli che fanno just dance mi
ha contattato e ha detto fa vj abbiamo
notato che sei bravo ballare che c'hai
le doti da ballerino che minchia stefano
de martino ti devi spostare è allora
facciamo una bella cosa facciamo che ti
mettiamo in una canzone di just dance
non è uno scherzo c'è ios sono in questo
just dance ci sono anche io
la cosa probabilmente vi fa ridere fa
ridere anche a me però è così uno
stefano de martino altro che belen dare
tutta la [ __ ] la prendo io mamma sono
diventato un ballerino dal nulla grazie
ragazzi questa è la è la cosa più bella
della vita e non so che dire grazie
della fiducia riposta in me non vi
deluderò con che sia ragazzi la mappa di
just dance esce il 24 settembre e che
cazzo di in sé magari esce il 24
novembre che sembrano ben manco i mesi
esce 24 novembre ed è scaricabile per
chi ha già state 2017 quindi il 24
novembre per chi a just dance 2017
scaricate la mappa che ci sono io ci
sono io da me questa è una foto che ho
fatto dove ci sono io che mi faccio la
foto farò ovviamente un video dove io
tento di imitarmi cioè io tento di sex
abete io provo sempre evitare i
ballerini ecco proverò a imitare me
stesso bene questa e credo sia stata una
delle news più etiche se non la più
epica da quando faccio i blog perché mi
chiamerà da soli direi che possiamo
passare al allo smistamento dei pacchi
che ormai casa mia è diventato peggio di
un centro amazon partiamo dal più
piccolo visto che il più piccolo e più
facilmente smi stabile the first one una
ma scatola nera ho paura di che cosa io
ci possa trovare dentro ma proviamo ad
aprirla c'e un una foto che questa
ragazza mi ha mandato che è stampata qua
adesso volevi maremma tuo paiola poi c'è
anche una collana a metà che credo sia
che credo che l'altra metà ce l'abbia
lei grazie faceva il prossimo the next
la meic cos'è sta roba
oddio due ong indiana jones usato 29
euro e ross sei bello solo 26 non c'è il
gioco dei lego nota non so veramente
adesso come faranno a sopravvivere the
next pacco ragazzi da san marino minchia
dall'estero dentro ci trovo delle armi
io stavo scherzando quando ho detto che
ci potrei trovare delle armi però c'è un
aspetto da te prenderli sul serio cos'è
star a non è un arma sono panarda eboli
perché ci sono dei soldi è che mi avete
inviato dei soldi adesso sì che fai big
money pistole soldi quanto è un pacco di
contrabbando questo mancano quattro
ragazzi miei questo è più easy come ho
fatto a vivere senza
come ho fatto a vivere senza porca [ __ ]
questo lo regala una ragazza avrò la sua
non è vero perché mi prendono c'è un
pastello perché c'è un pastello ecco il
mio simbolo d'amore per chiunque mi
abbiamo andato questo un regalo bene
comunque prossimo parco sempre di grossi
sempre i pacchi più grossi grossi più
dry e va beh questo la pro natale la
confezione signore e signori promette
bene ora sicuramente una pistola questa
grazie grazie delle
e vabbè però devi stare calmo e c'è
questo che non so se si vede ma è così
illumina bellissimo stranamente oggi è
un'espressione più intelligente del
solito meno tre ragazzi come somma il
piccolo però di solito quelli piccoli
sono quelli più insidiosi maghi maghetti
ma cos'è sono a pronzato tanto
abbronzato meno due ragazzi allora
questo è ancora sottile perfetto da
antongiulio c'è scritto qua da anton
antongiulio nome antongiulio te lo sei
inventato grazie va beh va bene questa è
una farsa
ok chicca sarà la farà della settimana
totò gli togli anton giulio nome una
garanzia affaccio ruga grazie
dai che ci hai capelli che sono più o
meno quelli bellissimi ringrazia
antongiulio vieni passare all'ultimo
pacco che è quello più grosso più grosso
di dei più grossi a posto ok ragazzi
questo dovrebbe essere fragile a
giudicare da sé perché ora questa che è
la più grossa di tutte
ti adoro sei fantastica come fai a
saperlo che mi piace no non è vero mai
nella vita come cazzo fai a saperlo
della mia gioco preferito ahia ahia ahia
retro gonna e retro gore qua non siamo
qua siamo sul tuo preferito però posso
istruirmi domani sono tutto tipo sarà
così ragazzi ve lo dico questa roba è
non è oro di più ce n'è veramente chi mi
tocca sta roba lo ammazzo degli occhiali
degli occhiali per per vips adesso sono
tutto vito anche all'ultima cosa il
diamante vsphere the diamond quello che
ho potuto da un milione di dollari
adesso ce l'ho qui vale un milione di
dollari questa roba anche gli occhiali
secondo me 4 fi casta maglietta quanto
rimorchio la [ __ ] consta maglietta
grazie tesoro si fantastica non è fatto
regalando ad onna e poi c'è una fan art
che non è una fan art ma e questo grazie
va beh veramente non so come come
ringraziarvi siete stati fantastici
nulla da togliere ad anton giulio
ragazzi miei spero che ai video vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate capito
l'importanza di aver ricevere i pacchi
anche se si accumulano uno sopra l'altro
alla fine se contengono queste cose si
scartano più che volentieri
ragazzi miei eroi aver subito vi sia
piaciuto cosi dice che bisogna far
momento è anna favi domanda veniteci all
alzheimer in realtà non è una favi
domanda ma mi stavo dimenticando i nervi
una cosa molto importante ho ripreso
adesso a fare lo scarafaggio dei pacchi
perché era da un po che non lo facevo la
prossima volta nel prossimo blog
farò un mega fa vi risponde solo di
risposte quindi fatemi tutte le domande
che voce alle quali volete che io
rispondo così nel blog del prossimo
sabato risponderò alla maggior parte
delle domande che l'innesco quindi fate
nei commenti taglio fare risponde due
punti domanda che volete e nel prossimo
vlog cercherò di rispondere il più
possibile alle domande che mi fate
chiedetemi qualsiasi cosa è anche quanto
porto di reggiseno che sicuramente meno
di greta menchi ma più della saab riemer
e ragazzi si prevede sia piaciuto
consentiti mi piace un argomento è un mi
piace ai capace di facebook e come
tiziana e cesare sede ci vediamo al
prossimo video bene ragazzi